what i want to do in this video is cover
something called the triple product
expansion or lagrange's formula
sometimes and it's really just a
simplification of the cross product of
three vectors so if i take the cross
product of a
and then
b cross c and what we're going to do is
we can express this we can express this
really as sum and differences of dot
products well not just dot products dot
products scaling different vectors
you're going to see what it means but it
simplifies this expression a good bit
because cross products are hard to take
they're computationally intensive and at
least in my mind they're confusing now
this isn't something you have to know if
you're going to be dealing with vectors
but it's a useful to know my motivation
for actually doing this video is i saw
some problems for the indian institute
of technology
entrance exam that seems to expect that
you know lagrange's formula or the
triple product expansion so let's see
how we can simplify this
so to do that let's start taking the
cross product let's start taking the
cross product of b and c and e in all of
these situations
i'm just going to assume let's say i
have vector a i'm just going to call
that that's going to be a
the x component of vector a times the
unit vector i plus the
y component
not b
plus the y component of vector a times
the unit vector j
plus the z component of vector a times
unit vector k and i could do the same
things for b and c so if i say b sub y
i'm talking about what's scaling the j
component in the b vector
so let's first take this cross product
over here and if you've seen me take
cross products you know that i like to
do these little determinants and what
let me just take it over here so b
b cross c
b cross c is going to be equal to the
determinant and i put an i j k up here i
j k this is actually the definition of
the cross product so no proof of
necessary to show you why this is true
this is just one way to remember the dot
product if you remember how to take
determinants of 3 by 3s
and we'll put b's x term
b's y
coefficient and b's
z
component and then you do the same thing
for the c c x c y
c z
and then this is going to be equal to so
first you have it's the i component so
it's going to be the i component
times b
so you
ignore this column in this row so b y c
z
b y
c z
minus b z c y minus so i'm just ignoring
all of this and i'm looking at this 2 by
2 over here minus b z c y
minus b z
c
y
and then we want to subtract the j
component remember we alternate signs
when we take our determinant subtract
that and then we take out that column
and that row so it's going to be it's
going to be b x c z
b x c z this is a little monotonous but
hopefully it'll have an interesting
result b x c z minus b z c x
minus
b z
minus b z
c x and then finally plus the k
component
okay we're going to have b x times c y
b x c y
minus b y c x minus b y
minus b by cx so this is this we just
did the dot product
and now we want to take the oh sorry we
just did the cross product i want to get
you confused we just took the cross
product of b and c and now we need to
take the cross product of that with a or
the cross product of a with this thing
right over here so let's do that instead
of rewriting the vector let me just set
up another another matrix here so let me
write my i
j
k up here and then let me write a's
component so we have a sub x
a sub y
a sub z
and then let's
clean this up a little bit let's ignore
this we're just looking at i want to do
that in black
let's do this in black so that we can
kind of erase that now this is a this is
a minus j times that so what i'm going
to do is i'm going to get rid of the
minus and the j
but i'm going to rewrite this with the
signs swap so this is going to be this
is going to swap the signs actually b z
c x minus
minus b x c
minus b x c z so let me delete
everything else so i just took the
negative and i multiplied it by this
i'm not making any careless mistakes
here so let me just i can make the brush
size a little bit bigger so i can erase
that a little more efficiently
there you go and then we also want to
get rid of that right over there now let
me get my brush size back down to normal
size
all right so now let's just take this
cross product so once again set it up as
set it up as a determinant and what i'm
only going to focus on because it'll
take the video or it'll take me forever
if i were to do
if i were to do the i j and k components
i'm just going to focus on the i
component just on the
x component of this cross product and
then we can
see that we'll get the same result for
the j and the k and then we can see what
hopefully this simplifies down to so if
we just focus on the i component here
this is going to be
this is going to be i
i times and we just look at this 2 by 2
matrix right over here we ignored i's
column i's row and we have
a y times all of this
so let me just multiply it out so it's a
y
a y times b x
c y
minus
minus a y times b y
times b y c x
b y c x and then we're going to want to
subtract we want to have minus a z times
this so let's just do that so it's minus
or negative
a
z
b
c
x and then we have a negative a z times
this so it's plus
a z
b x
c
z
and now what i'm going to do this is a
little bit of a trick for this proof
right here just so that it just so that
we get the results that i want i'm just
going to add and subtract the exact same
thing so i'm going to add
i'm going to add an ax
bx
cx and then i'm going to subtract an ax
bx cx minus
ax
b
x
b x
c x so clearly i have not changed this
expression i've just added and
subtracted the same thing
and let's see what we can simplify
remember this is this is just the x
component of our triple product just the
x component but to do this let me factor
out
i'm going to factor out a b sub x so let
me do this
let me get the b
sub x so if i were to factor it out and
i'm only going to look at i'm going to
factor out of this term that has a b sub
x i'm going to factor out of this term
and then i'm going to factor it out of
this term so if i take the b sub x out
i'm going to have an a
y
c y actually let me write it a little
bit differently let me factor it let me
factor it out of this one first so then
it's an a it's it's going to have an ax
cx
a sub x c sub x so i use this one up and
then i'm going to have a i'll do this
one now plus if i factor the b sub x out
i get a sub y
c sub y i've used that one now and now i
have this one i'm going to factor the b
sub x out so i'm left with a plus
a sub z
c sub z so that's all of those so i
factored that out and now from these
from these right over here let me factor
out a negative c sub x
uh negative c sub x
and so if i do that let me go to this
term right over here i'm going to have
an ax bx when i factor it out so an ax
bx cross that out and then over here i'm
going to have an a y b y remember i'm
factoring out a negative c sub x so i'm
going to have a plus
a sub y
b sub y
and then finally i'm going to have a
plus a sub z
a sub z
b
sub z
and what is this
well this right here in green this is
the exact same thing as the dot products
of a and c
this is the dot product of the vectors a
and c it's the dot product
of this vector and that vector so that's
a
the dot of a and c
times the x component of b
times the x component
minus
i'll do this in the same minus once
again this is the dot product of a and b
now
minus a dot b
a dot b
times the x component of c and we can't
forget all of this was multiplied by the
unit vector i we're looking at the the
the x component of the i component of
that whole triple product so that's
going to be
all of this
it's all of this is being is times the
unit vector i now if we do this exact
same thing and i'm not going to do it
because it's it's
computationally intensive but i think it
would it won't be a huge leap of faith
for you if this is for the x component
if i were to do the exact same thing for
the y component for the j component so
it'll be plus
if i do the same thing for the j
component we can really just pattern
match we have we have b sub x c sub x
that's for the x component well we'll
have b sub y
and c sub y for the j component and then
this is not component specific so it'll
be
a
it will be a dot
a dot c over here and minus a dot b over
here you can verify any of these for
yourself if you don't believe me but
it's the exact same process we just did
and then finally for the z component or
the k component let me put parentheses
over here same idea you're going to have
b sub z
c
sub
z and then you're going to have a dot b
a dot b over there and then you're going
to have
a
dot
c
over here now what is what does this
what is this become
how can we simplify this
well this right over here we can expand
this out we can factor out an a dot c
from all of these terms over here
remember this is going to be multiplied
times i actually let me not let me not
skip too many steps just because i want
to i want you to believe what i'm doing
so this if we expand the i here instead
of rewriting it let me just
let me just do it like this it's a
little bit messier but let me just so i
could write this i there and that i
there i'm kind of just distributing that
x that x unit vector or the i unit
vector and let me do the same thing for
j
so i could put the j there and i could
put the j right over there and then i
could do the same thing for the k
put the k there and then put the k there
and now what are these well this
this part right over here
is exactly the same thing
as a
dot c
a dot c
times and i'll write it out here
b x b sub x times i plus b sub y times j
plus b sub y times j
plus
b
sub z
times k
and then from that we're going to
subtract all of this a dot b
we're going to subtract a
dot b
times the exact same thing and you're
going to notice this right here is the
same thing as vector b
that is vector b when you do it over
here you're going to get vector c so
i'll just write over here
you're just going to get vector c so
just like that we have we have a
simplification for our triple product
i know it took us a long time to get
here but this is a simplification it
might not look like one but
computationally it is it's easier to do
if i have i'll try to color code it a
cross
a cross
b cross let me do in all different
colors c
we just saw that this is going to be
equivalent to and one way to think about
it is it's going to be you take the
first vector times the dot product of
the the first vector in this in this
second dot product the one that we have
our parentheses around the one we would
have to do first you take your first
vector there so it's vector b
and you multiply that times the dot
product of the other two vectors
so a
dot c
a dot c and from that you subtract you
subtract
the second vector you subtract the
second vector multiplied by the dot
product of the other two vectors
of a
a
dot
b and we're done this is our triple
product
this is our triple product expansion now
once again this isn't this isn't
something that you really have to know
you could always obviously multiply you
could actually just do this you know
you don't have to you could do it by
hand you don't have to know this but if
you have really hairy
vectors or if this is com some type of
math competition and sometimes it
simplifies real fast when you reduce it
to dot products this is a useful thing
to know for lagrange's formula or the
triple product expansion